J'aimerais apprendre au monde à chanter en
parfaite harmonie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la bouteille de coca a cent ans
cette année
wow c'est encore plus vieux que moi
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bunny n'a aucune utilité à tout moment
pour moi, mais mais l'argent en termes de
voyages ou de faire seulement plus de
maisons ou d'avoir un bateau ou quelque chose qui
ne m'est d'aucune utilité Je ne pourrais pas attraper une
maladie qui porte mon nom alors je  'd réunis
pour une taxe
[Music]
dans les prochaines semaines, nous allons voter
sur quelque chose que nous appelons la règle Buffett
très simple si vous gagnez plus d'un
million de dollars par an, alors ce que
dit la règle, c'est que vous devriez payer le même
pourcentage  de votre revenu en impôts en tant que
familles de la classe moyenne, il y a eu
quelques choses dites par Donald Trump au cours
des dernières semaines
[Musique]
attendez, vous entendrez, je suis un homme, vous êtes vraiment
stand
[Musique]
définissant votre cercle de  la compétence est
l'aspect le plus important de l'investissement
ce n'est pas l'importance de la taille de votre
cercle vous n'avez pas besoin d'être un expert
sur tout mais de savoir où se trouve et reste le
périmètre de ce cercle de ce que vous
savez sur lequel vous ne savez pas
à l'intérieur de tout cela est important
[Musique]